all four Russians are waiting with bated  breath for a phone call from me they  know that two of them are about to leave  the competition a chance  it's all on this phone call Baylor  as a restaurant I'll help you hi oh hey  Monsieur hi Simon  hello I'm good I have to eliminate zoo  is not going any further in the  competition that's no problem thank you  very much  sorry no worries okay thank you  merci beaucoup Monsieur Beauvoir I said  stops here it's really disappointing for  not winning I am like gutted I wanted to  win this competition with my soul I'm  taking a break  not gonna get easier Simon I am really  fine but you guys gonna have to keep on  working hard  congratulations  Cheers I've just had a heart oh well  done take care thank you I can't put  into words how much it means to me  personally it's the biggest thing I've  ever done in my career